you know the saying goes the justice is
blind I think they got it backwards
justice likes to watch black maritime
once again second episode of the second
season white bear whoo boy okay
this was quite a viewing experience
because you know what it is that's going
on just unfolds in these sort of peeling
back of layers as it goes along and by
the end it just really leaves you in a
state where I it's like you don't know
what to make of it I don't mean in terms
of the plot you know exactly what went
on in terms of plot but like emotionally
you don't know what to make of this
setup if you haven't figured already
spoilers so there's your warning so this
whole thing now the the lead actress in
this I know from being human which it
was a show I really wanted to like but
didn't but she was good and she she did
you know she was very convincing in the
harrowing moments of this and selling
that all the other performers were
really good too especially because there
any that say most of everybody else had
to play effectively dual roles both in
and out of character so to speak so the
way that it opens it felt honestly
initially it felt kind of contrived like
especially compared to what I usually
get from baikonur I'm like oh it's kind
of like the purge and that the signal or
whatever it was that horror movie from a
few years ago about a television single
that makes people go crazy that I saw
the trailer for them was like I don't
want to watch that it's like those two
things together although I'm pretty sure
it predates both of them in any case the
you know I I'm like okay yeah you know
it's well executed but it felt it felt
like a weirdly contrived setup so I part
of me was thinking there's got to be
more to this than what I'm seeing cuz
otherwise this doesn't feel particularly
black mirror you know it feels a little
to just I can't think of a better word
and tribe but of course then we get our
first wrinkle which is you know people
just watching and you know the
explanation we get is that that's how it
affected most people with a signal but
at the same time you're like boy that
really has that weird feeling of because
I mean it's it's something that we that
we encounter to a certain degree in the
real world which is that people don't
intervene we just watch we record we
playback we don't interact and playing
that up for horror from the perspective
of someone who is surrounded by people
who are watching but not helping that
that the episode sold that really well
the whole thing with you know the
killer's with the guns and the the
carving knife and the drill and all this
stuff like that that was fine and kept
them moving at least you know that was
my thought as I was watching it and you
know they're getting ready to sort of
disrupt the signal I was expecting to
not get a full explanation as to what
the signal was I figured we just get
whatever her backstory was you know why
she doesn't remember and whatnot and
then then we get the full proper reveal
and of course we've gotten flashes of
this little girl and the implication of
course and her assumption being that it
was her daughter and not only was it not
her daughter but this child is dead she
watched it happen and did nothing to
stop it she just watched she just filmed
and realizing what it is that has
happened this very much deliberate
forcing her to feel what that little
girl must have felt that someone is
right there who's watching who should be
helping and who isn't and making her
feel that on mass over and over and over
again
but the thing is because you start with
her and because it does a really good
job of zeroing in on her panic her
paying her terror
you've been sympathizing with her up to
this point and then you get this reveal
and at first you're like oh okay I get
that's kind of an eye-for-an-eye thing
but then you know you realize oh they do
this to her every single day and it's a
little it's a little bit like a
Clockwork Orange kind of turned inside
out and by that I mean Clark record and
started you out with the character that
age showed you how terrible he was then
had him go through a day know presented
as a punishment but it cure that is
terrifying and awful and you find
yourself sympathizing with somebody who
you already know is terrible and this
kind of does the same thing but in
Reverse which is that you start out
sympathizing with someone and then find
out why it is that they are being
treated this way and you so rather than
being brought to sympathize or someone
you already know is awful you find out
with someone who you sympathize with was
awful but even though they both sort of
do it in the opposite order the end
result of both this and Clark orange is
effectively the same which is it makes
you go I can't say that they didn't
deserve what they got but this just kind
of feels wrong it feels icky it feels
cruel but you can't actually make much
of an argument against it it's it's this
wonderfully conflicted feeling you come
away from it with this from because the
kind of thing that she did that she took
part in I think that's something that
the vast majority of us if we read about
here about you know see a news story
what have you our first instinct is
whatever punishment they get is too good
for them
well this show kind of came up with
something that I
think you can argue is too good for them
it may I'm not sure I can argue that
that it's too harsh though either
because it is just meeting out exactly
what she dealt but at the same time
there's this whole thing of is it fair
to not only punish someone repeatedly
you know I'm just punishing her you're
punishing her again and again and again
and again and she doesn't know why so
it's not even well it's it clearly it's
not a case of rehabilitation or you know
or anything like that that's completely
off the table but is it even really a
proper punishment if she doesn't know
that's what it is if every time she goes
through it she doesn't understand that
this is happening to her because of
something she did until the very end
and even at that point you know she's
probably only just starting to get the
memories back so it's like something
that maybe she understands
intellectually but she doesn't she
doesn't know she's paying for something
that in a way the person that they reset
her to at the start of every day that
person didn't really do this but the
person who did do this kind of deserves
what they're getting it's it just really
leaves you in a weird head space of am i
awful for part of me being okay with
this or flipside am i awful that I don't
think someone who is directly involved
in the brutal murder of a child doesn't
deserve this
I think either either one of your
leanings on whether or not you know what
your instinct is I think you're gonna
find yourself conflicted about it in
terms of how this episode presents
everything and that's just that's just
solid writing that's just I get what
this show does possibly better than any
other show I've seen on television is
just execute its concepts at the highest
level for the max
impact and the harshest possible
delivery of whatever it is that it's
doing because more often than not the
ideas and the concepts and the general
you know maybe even some of the ideas of
the technology is probably not brand new
look at which I mean it wouldn't be
because a lot of these are sort of
almost logical extrapolations of stuff
we kind of have so you kind of get what
what's going on so it's not like it's
coming up with insanely inventive core
concepts but the execution of those
concepts and the way that they tie into
the themes that each episode is dealing
with is it's it's masterful and then for
it to always be in service of this weird
conflicted sinking uh feeling but so
many of these episodes leave you with
although in an odd way like I'm almost
energized by this one like I think it's
because I I started watching and going
God that seems oddly straightforward and
then ending on this feeling of like
being so conflicted and not knowing
whether or not I Mac I'm okay with what
it is that happened and at this point
like I say I'm oddly energized by that
because I'm just in awe of the execution
of these things and I I have a feeling
that when I wake up in the morning I
might have like a bit of an emotional
hangover but right now I'm just I'm just
kind of riding the high of having gone
through watching this thing unfold it's
really really good so white bear this is
one of those ones that a lot of people
in comments were like I can't you know
wait till you get to white bear so I
don't know if people were expecting me
to be like devastated by this if the
death of the young child had been had
felt like more of a rug pull maybe I
would have been because obviously I've
talked about before you know endangered
children is kind of a bit of a button
for me that gets pushed I think in this
case though as soon as we got
flashes her I'm like something horrible
happened to that kid so knowing that
already finding out that it was her that
was directly involved in that wasn't as
harsh a punch as if I just hadn't known
ahead of time to something awful is
gonna happen to my kid I think I called
that early enough so again I if anyone
who is coming in on my other videos was
like can't wait V disease I'm curious as
to what you thought my reaction to this
episode was gonna be and whether what my
reaction actually is surprises you or
not whether you have something to
contribute along those lines or if you
just want to give me your thoughts about
everything in general white bear what
did you think about it drop your
thoughts down in the comments let's talk
about it and there's all those things
you can do support me on patreon follow
me on Twitter listen to my podcast links
for all that stuff sound in the
description you know how this works so
until next time this council is
adjourned
[Music]
you
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]